so you were deep in uh how did you get
so deep in because I don't think anyone
would look at you and think this is the
Coke guy good that was the whole thing
um I mean I certainly tried to talk
about it on stage as having had like a
drug and alcohol problem but it just I
don't know yeah it didn't something
about me seems
so to me it's like well of course the
guy that seems like he has it all
together has the problem because that's
just like how life is that's Texas yeah
it's almost like this textbook yeah
um
but that's I I don't put that on other I
don't put that on you to be like how
come you didn't see it because I was I
also I really thought like
I really thought that I was doing life I
was able to achieve it life with the
drugs as opposed to In Spite of them it
took me a long time over the past couple
years to realize that I did well at what
I do in spite of drugs not because of
them wow yeah yeah because it would be
fun yeah from an outsider I would always
look at him and be like oh that guy yeah
drugs would not help that guy
like that guy is his own he is so unique
in his own way that anything to uh like
a a a base that or something or debase
that would only mess him up but I would
have thought I would have thought like
I'm delivering something people really
like and I think I'm delivering it
because I take two 30 milligram
Adderalls and then one z-bar and so I'm
really sharp but I don't seem jittery
and so I go on a podcast or I go on a
talk show and I'm just I'm delivering
and I'm giving people what I'm naturally
good at but I'm a little tired so I
can't naturally do it so it's okay it's
okay to take it's okay to rip open time
release Adderall and dump the beads down
my throat and then pop a Klonopin
because then I will get to the level
that I naturally am at like I just gotta
deliver what I'm good at and right now
we're running on a lean mixture and it
used to be easier but now it's harder so
whatever I'm putting in my body to get
to that is fine so cocain and you liked
cocaine Xanax Klonopin Adderall Percocet
riddle in any kind of speed oh so all
that speed huh
um would you get I would get so scared
at night when I was high on cocaine
right yeah
that I would be like Googling what can I
take with cocaine to go to sleep
and that would take me so many hours to
I'd look at so many there'd be like you
get on these answer sites and people's
like you're you go to Florida yeah yeah
I go to quora right or whatever that is
right yeah yeah count hey count now from
60 and you'll be dead people would say
stuff like that and you're just like oh
my so you didn't have like because
that's the thing I I actually you didn't
take any downers I didn't take any
downers so I would lay there in misery I
would Google like can I go may I ask did
you know about downers
I guess I knew about them but I just had
never taken them and I was so scared to
mix something with cocaine because oh it
would kill me that's what I was fearful
that was your worry yeah
um I kind of thought if I if I didn't
have the right balance
yeah I was more like if I don't have
enough in the right amounts then
something bad could happen but as long
as I'm balancing coconateral with Xanax
and Klonopin I'll be justified I
remember I walked into my intervention I
just been to my drug dealers department
and I finally got the right balance oh
yeah one pocket all Adderall and Coke
one pocket all Xanax and I was like I
have done it I reached equilibrium yeah
open the door
people yeah it's okay though were you
high when you went to Europe yes but I
was insisting that I hadn't used drugs
in days I went look I am sober right now
look at me I am sober right now I kept
saying and were you good enough to
convince those people that you were no I
was pretty strung out by then so it
didn't I I I could present really well
for a long time yeah but I'd reached a
point where
um it was just off the rails I'm seeing
that about you you're a very good
presenter
um it's a yeah a a doctor at rehab was
like it scares me how good you are at
presenting like everything's fine wow
yeah were you surprised that you were an
addict or did you know you were an
addict
um I had like
Skin Deep self-awareness of like I have
a drug problem uh I'm I love drugs I
like them too much I don't like them the
way other people like them it's not like
oh that was fun let's do that again in
two weeks this was like I think I think
the plan for the morning should be to
get more of that
um I knew I liked them more than other
people but I it was
but no not to the depth that it was what
do I mean to say I had us I had a
surface level awareness and I would joke
about that and and say you know oh I got
sober in 2005 which I did but I slowly
got back into Pharmaceuticals over the
next you know 13 14 years prescribed
than not prescribed or prescribed then
abused but prescribed then bought on the
street then everything will you buy them
off of Craigslist and stuff like that
even no I always thought that might be
cops
smart
um
and it's depressed pills it's a lot of
like I have friends oh this was even
before I had an awareness that there
might be fakes out there like that yeah
um I've definitely bought Adderall a
couple times and snorted it and thought
this is what is this yeah oh I bought a
whole thing of something one time and
did it all and it wasn't it wasn't
cocaine nope no God and I don't know
what it is and I still imagine one day
I'm gonna walk past a chemical and
and it's going to connect a little oh
you'll smell it or something you smell a
chemical and you remember that that was
what you bought he'd be like oh it was
me or something you know what I'm saying
yeah uh no it the um the realization
that I actually
had no control over this
took a long time wow
it's a hard thing for people to convince
it's a hard I mean I still struggle
sometimes even if I sit in a meeting and
there's still part of me that doesn't
want to say I'm an alcoholic
yeah or an addict I to me I go it's more
complicated than that yeah like you
don't get it it's not
it's not that I'm like it's not that
just that cocaine's addictive and when I
do it I'm addicted it's it's a different
thing I use it in a different way and
the way I see it in my relationship with
it it's just yeah I kind of have a
romance it's like a i romanticize it 100
I write everything in my life me too
yeah those like being in Midtown
Manhattan have a meeting have a you know
have a big like production meeting on
something
um and you could be able to get there
get there half hour late uh
uh desperate to have a cigarette so like
finding an abandoned office and smoking
out the window and being almost very
much in trouble and it being really
clear those moments were so about
surviving that that hour that they NE I
never thought about them with any deeper
perspective I never thought oh my God
what has my life become I was just like
I
it would be easier to take the train I'd
be faster to take the train home to my
cocaine but I can't do Coke on the train
so it was all just like figuring out the
video game of being a drug addict wow
took up it was just a Scramble for the
present problem and as soon as that
problem was solved I moved on I wasn't
like I can't believe you know I remember
I went
I went into a meeting holding a bottle
of Pedialyte because I was not eating
anything I was just drinking Pedialyte
doing cocaine and I was I was with
people I knew and we were waiting for
other people to join the meeting that we
didn't know and I said if my nose bleeds
or if I pass out it's because I have a
sinus infection don't worry you know and
I'll give a signal if I think I'm about
to pass out and then
then and even to them I was like because
I'm sick right that's why wow yeah
what's the signal too I can't remember
Geronimo
um that'd be a great thing to say before
you pass out and your nose explodes with
blood yeah that that covered it well did
you ever end up in a really cool place
doing drugs
I'm meaning the geographic Place yeah
just like a dicey like you know shonies
or something you know some place that
was a little deviant you know
um karaoke bar
I'm trying to think like were you that
were you that guy that wanted to get
deep into the Trap houses and [__] were
you like kind of like the um
uh who was it got Anthony Bourdain of
like trap houses and stuff like that
did Anthony what's a trap a trap house
is just like a place where people are
doing drugs and there's like a lady
who's like probably like you know if you
wake her up she would have sex maybe
like in the back it's like Anthony
Bourdain went to these no he didn't but
he wanted like food places he went to
restaurants yeah right or you like that
uh yeah are you like would you be that
guy like or is that kind of your like
some people like to get into the depths
of the of the 5 a.m you know and like
just the like how weird can I get you no
my the weirdest times for me were the
days because I was I mean that feeling
of
you know when you haven't slept and the
whole world has yeah just the way that
that warmth you feel in your bones
you're going into Starbucks or like
man like just running an errand and
you're like does everyone know can
everyone tell there's just something
kind of like shinier about us yeah you
know like
something like sleeker we're just a
faster animal because like we didn't
just lay down for eight hours
oh I'm sure you are more alert huh oh
you're like an alley cat
like an alley cat
yeah and you're like a [__] very but
you're like but things also become far
more complicated right oh I would
overthink things overthink everything
you're like a ghost you're like a fast
[__] like a Tesla ghost and you're
like these clothes don't look like
someone put them on this morning yeah
these look like yesterday clothes yeah
not even at their wrinkle not even
anything just you just have an air about
you that says I did not just rest yeah
but I think no one can tell
if you're still gacked up enough to
converse
yeah
[__] I would be so scared dude I would
walk
yeah my depth perception would feel
weird yeah it's a lot of like cat you
know cars everything's coming in yeah
everything's coming fast oh
god dude they're a disaster how yeah
drugs are a disaster and that's a nice
thing to not have to worry about anymore
isn't it oh my God
yeah that is not I'm not in a crisis all
the time I don't judge people for having
a harsh view of
addicts a lot of people have addicts in
their lives and you can't just go it's a
disease and I you know like it it can
really
um
it's very painful to other people yeah
oh yeah I mean it's a mess they're a
mess yeah life's so hard already life's
like
life's like a table piled high with so
much [__] like a bad you know when you
go to like a little restaurant in a tiny
circular ass table and they don't have
room for anything oh yeah table pile
type of [__] and drugs come in and drugs
you think are gonna solve all your
problems and they kick the legs out from
under it yeah they're just a mess
it's it's they're a disaster
they're a disaster
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one